وبعيدا عن اجواء اللعبه واكثر قرب من
فعالياتها المبهجه كان الجماهير فاكهه
الحدث الكبير وكانت الملاعب ما كانت
تالقها هذه الملاعب التي تختلف مصائرها
بعد نهايه كاس العالم قطر 2022
وقبيل كاس العالم وضعت قطر خطه لاجل
الملاعب المونديال التي تختلف مصائرها بعد
نهايه البطوله التاريخيه لمونديال 20 22
ستاد روسيا للاكبر في البطوله ستعمل قطر
على تحويله لمجمع فيه العديد من المدارس
والمساكن والمحل والعيادات الطبيه مع
تحويل مرافقه لخدمه مدينه لوسيل الجديده
مع الحفاظ على شكله الخارجي
استاذ المدينه التعليميه سيتم تقليس ساعته
الى 20,000 مقعد ويبقى كم مركز رياضي
للمنتخب الوطني القطري للسيدات
استعدت امامه والجنوب سيبقىان على وضعهما
مع تقليص مقاعدهما الى النصف اي نحو
20,000 مقعد فقط لكل الملعب استاذ احمد بن
علي سيتحول لمقر لنادي الريان القطري
وتقلص مقاعده الى 20 الف مقعد مع منح
المقاعد المفككه لمشاريع تطوير كره القدم
حول العالم استاد البيت او الخيمه سيتم
تفكيك الجزء العلوي من هو تقليل العدد
مقاييجي الى 32 الف مقعد وتبرع بالمقاعد
المفكره استاذ خليفه الدولي سيبقى على
حاله كما قال لي اكاديميه ومجمع للالعاب
المائيه
مشفى للطب الرياضي اما الساعه 974 وهو
المصنوع من حاويات قابله لتفكيك سيتم
تفكيكه بالكامل والتبرع به لاحدى الدول
الناميه لتعمري رياضه